>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
HAPPY GLORIOUS, GLORIOUS
THURSDAY.
WOW.
WHAT A CROWD, HUH?
GLORIOUS CROWD.
WHAT A WEEK FOR CROOKS,
SCHEMEERS AND LIARS, OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS DEMOCRATS.
THAT WAS CHEAP AND I APOLOGIZE.
NOT REALLY.
BUT PART OF A NEW SEGMENT I LIKE
TO CALL
♪♪
>> THESE ARE TERRIBLE PEOPLE!
WHO SUCK!
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
THAT WAS CREATED BY MY NEPHEW
ALLEN FOR HIS ART CLASS.
THEY LIKE TO KEEP THE INMATES
BUSY.
HE'LL BE OUT IN THREE YEARS.
SO FIRST DURING QUESTIONING BY
SPECIAL COUNSEL JOHN DURHAM ON
TUESDAY AN FBI ANALYST CLAIMS
THE FBI OFFERED EX BRITISH AGENT
CHRISTOPHER STEEL A MILLION
BUCKS IF HE COULD CORROBORATE
THE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
CANDIDATE TRUMP THAT WERE MADE
IN THE DOSSIER BACK IN 2016.
NOW TALK ABOUT CREATING AN
INCENTIVE TO LIE, OFFERING SEVEN
FIGURES FOR A PEE TAPE.
HELL I COULD HAVE MADE ONE FOR
HIM FOR FOUR, FIVE HUNDRED
BUCKS.
IN THE FOX NEWS MEN'S ROOM.
OR BEST OFFER.
KNEEL CA VETO OWES ME A FAVOR.
PLUS HE LOOKS GOOD IN A WIG AND
CAN DO A RUSSIAN ACCENT.
BUT WHY SO MUCH MONEY?
COULD IT BE THAT STEEL WOULD
NEED PART OF THAT MONEY TO PAY
THE CORROBORATEERS?
HE GETS PAID PERHAPS TO PAY OFF
WITNESSES?
IT'S ENTIRELY POSSIBLE.
AT ANY RATE THE WHOLE THING IS
SEEDIER THAN A PUMPKIN CARVING
CONTESTMENT PERHAPS IF THE
REPUBLICANS HAD DONE THIS, THE
MEDIA MIGHT CARE.
MEANWHILE PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID
TUESDAY THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE SAUDIS NOT
DELAYING THE CUT IN OIL
PRODUCTION UNTIL DAYS BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS IN ORDER TO HELP THE
DEMS.
AND THEY SAID TRUMP WAS DAMAGING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR ALLIES.
REMEMBER WHEN HE TOLD GERMANY TO
GET OFF RUSSIAN ENERGY?
NOW HE LOOKS LIKE A PSYCHIC
WHILE BIDEN LOOKS LIKE MILTON
BURREL'S CORPS.
BUT THE SAUDIS TOLD JOE TO STUFF
IT AND NOW DEMS ARE INTRODUCING
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD PAUSE ALL
ARM SALES TO THE SAUDIS FORA
YEAR.
RIGHT NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY FOOT TO ALL THE
DEMS ASSES.
SO THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE IS
PUNISHING AN ALLY BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T HELP THEM POLITICALLY.
ISN'T THAT WHAT THEY IMPEACHED
TRUMP FOR WITH THAT PERFECT
PHONE CALL?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YEAH.
THERE'S THAT -- I'LL TAKE IT.
THERE'S THAT GOLDEN RULE AGAIN,
WHATEVER THE DEMS ACCUSE YOU OF
YOU CAN BET THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING IT.
ALSO SHOWS BIDEN REALLY DIDN'T
CARE ABOUT AMERICANS PAYING FOR
MORE FOR GAS TO HIM IT'S ABOUT
POLITICS BECAUSE AT THIS RACE
HIS PARTY'S GOING TO LOSE MORE
SEATS THAN A PATIO FURNITURE
STORE DURING A CATEGORY 5.
BUT IF THE REPUBLICANS HAD DONE
THIS PERHAPS THE MEDIA MIGHT
CARE.
THIS ENTHERE'S THAT CHROME DOMED
GRAM LIN, ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS
OPPOSES USING THE TERM ALIEN
BECAUSE HE LOOKS LIKE ONE.
TRUE, ARE WE SURE HE'S NOT FROM
OUTER SPACE?
I BET HIS WIFE'S NAME IS MINDY.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S RIGHT IN OUR AUDIENCES
WHEEL HOUSE, SIT-COMS FROM THE
70s.
IN A BOMBSHELL REVELATION,
MAYORKAS OWN STAFF A REPORT OF
AGENT WHIPPING MIGRANTS WAS
FALSE BEFORE HE WENT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE BUT HE WENT AHEAD
ANYWAY AND SMEARED HIS OWN
AGENTS AS RACIST JUST HOURS
BEFORE HE WAS TOLD THE OFFICER
WERE INNOCENT HE SAID THIS.
>> OUR ENTIRE NATION SAW
HORRIFYING IMAGES THAT DO NOT
REFLECT WHO WE ARE.
WE KNOW THAT THOSE IMAGES
PAINFULLY CON INJURED UP THE
WORST ELEMENTS OF OUR NATION'S
ONGOING BATTLE AGAINST SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
>> Greg: HEY, ASS WIPE, WE KNOW
WHO WE ARE, IT'S NOT WHO YOU
ARE, A LYING BACK STABBING HOUR
HUNGRY FINGER POINTING DIRT BAG
THAT WOULD SELL OUT HIS OWN MOM
AT THE DROP OF A HAT.
HE'S A SCUM BAG.
I KNOW THAT COULD BE DEFAMATION.
I GOT APPLAUSE FOR THAT.
I PREACHILY SHOULDN'T SAY THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT SCUM BAGS
TO SUE ME BUT HE LET HIS AGENTS
TWIST IN THE WIND FOR POLITICAL
ADVANTAGE PERHAPS TO SHIFT THE
MEDIA SPOTLIGHT AWAY FROM HIS
DISASTROUS LEADERSHIP TO THE
AGENTS FABRICATED RACIST
BEHAVIOR AND THE MEDIA BOUGHT
IT.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S PRETTY HARD TO
USE A WHIP WHILE YOU'RE ON A
FAST-MOVING HORSE.
YOU'D END UP WHIPPING YOURSELF
LIKE WHEN HEMMER AND I ROLE
PLAY.
SORRY.
AND EVEN AFTER IT WAS OBVIOUS
THEY WERE WRONGLY ACCUSED, HE
PROMISED THERE WOULD BE AN
INVESTIGATION, AND THERE WAS.
IT TOOK A YEAR.
AND THOUGH IT CLEARED THE
AGENTS, THEY STILL FACED
PUNISHMENT FOR OTHER SO-CALLED
VIOLATIONS.
AND WHAT WOULD THOSE BE, DOING
THEIR JOB AMID THE BORDER CHAOS
CAUSED BY THE WHITE HOUSE,
FILING WASH THE MUD OFF THEIR
UNIFORMS AFTER A HARD DAY'S
WORK.
USING THE WRONG PRONOUN WHEN
ADDRESSING THE HORSE?
I THINK IT'S NEY.
I DON'T KNOW.
THE WORST PART, MAYORKAS WAS
CLEARLY UNFAIR ON PURPOSE AND AS
YOU KNOW THAT'S THE MEDIA'S JOB.
SO WHAT DOES ALL THIS CORRUPTION
HAVE IN COMMON?
IT'S THE DEMOCRATS DOING THE
DIRTY DEEDS IN PLAIN SIGHT AND
YOU CAN ONLY DO THAT IF YOU HAVE
HELP A PROTECTIVE BIG BROTHER OR
BIG SISTER OR A BIG BROTHER WHO
WAS ONCE YOUR BIG SISTER.
HAVE I COVERED ALL THE NEW
[BLEEP] CATEGORIES?
AND THAT'S THE MEDIA WHO TURN
OFF THEIR CAMERAS AND CLOSE
THEIR NOTEBOOKS WHENEVER
DEMOCRATS SCHEME.
YOU COULD ARGUE THEY'RE THE REAL
EXCUSE ME BECAUSE WITHOUT THEM
THE POLITICAL EXCUSE ME WOULDN'T
HAVE COVER.
BUT IN A JUST WORLD THE PEOPLE
WHO PUSH THE STEAL DOSSIER WOULD
BE OCCUPYING THE VERY CELLS THAT
WOULD THE JANUARY 6TH PROTESTERS
ARE OCCUPYING NOW.
BIDEN WOULD BE IMPEACHED OR THE
25TH AMENDMENT WOULD PUT HIM IN
A NURSING ROOM HOPEFULLY ONE NOT
BEING RUN BY ANDREW CUOMO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: BUT -- AND, FINALLY,
MAYORKAS WOULD BE TARRED AND
FEATHERED WHICH ISN'T TOO BAD
FOR HIM SINCE HE CAN STILL GET
WORK AS AN OSTRICH.
>> PERIOD!
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
SHE'S SO EVIL, SHE JUST TOOK A
JOB ON THE SABBATH.
HOST OF FOX NEWS SUNDAY, SHANNON
BREAM!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HIS COMEDY CAREER IS ON
FIRE WHEN CUSTOMERS BURN DOWN
THE CLUB.
HOST OF FOX ACROSS AMERICA,
JIMMY FAILLA!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SHE'S LIKE A SQUIRREL.
TINY AND CUTE, BUT MIGHT HAVE
RABIES.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, KAT TIMPF
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: AND HE'S SO POWERFUL
THE NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE
NAMES HIS SNEEZES.
THAT'S GOOD.
MY MASSIVE SIDE KICK AND THE NWA
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION,
TYRUS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THERE IT IS.
SHANNON, SHANNON CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR NEW JOB.
>> Shannon: THANK YOU.
YOU LOBBIED AGAINST IT DIDN'T
YOU?
>> Greg: THAT'S WHY I CALLED YOU
EVIL BECAUSE I WANTED THEM TO
MOVE YOU TO SUNDAY AND TURN IT
INTO THE BLACK SABBATH.
>> Shannon: OH, NO.
WE BRING LIGHT.
>> Greg: YES.
VERY GOOD AND NOW WE HAVE DREAMY
TRACE GALLAGHER.
>> Shannon: I KNOW.
I NEED TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
NICKNAME, ALTHOUGH I WILL GIVE
YOU THAT.
>> Greg: HE IS DREAMY.
SHANNON THERE ARE THREE ELEMENTS
TO THE MONOLOGUE, WHAT BOTHERS
YOU THE MOST AND WHY?
>> Shannon: WELL, I THINK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT INITIALLY HIS
COMMENTS WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
AGENTS.
WE ARE ASKING THEM DO AN INSANE
JOB DOWN THERE AT THE BORDER SO
FOR THE HEAD BOSS GUY TO
INITIALLY LOOK LIKE HE WAS
COMING TO THEIR AID AND THEN IN
THE INTERIM GET AN E-MAIL THAT
SAYS THE PHOTOGRAPHER ON THIS
THING SAYS THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
AND THEN TO PLAY THE COMMENTS HE
MADE IS REALLY DIFFICULT TO
JUSTIFY.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK HE MIGHT
HAVE NOT KNOWN?
LET ME PUT IT THIS WAY.
DO YOU THINK THAT BIDEN ALSO
KNEW AND DIDN'T CARE EITHER?
>> I DON'T KNOW WE HAVE THE
E-MAIL BECAUSE SOMEBODY FOIAED
IT WHICH IS HOW WE GET ANSWERS
IN WASHINGTON SO WE KNOW IT GOT
TO MAYORKAS SO WHY HE MADE THOSE
COMMENTS INITIALLY DEFENDED THE
AGENTS AND THEN SAW THE E-MAIL
AND THEN
>> Greg: LOVE HOW YOU USED
FOYA AS A VERB.
>> Shannon: ONLY IN WASHINGTON.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT A REAL WORD.
BEGINNING TO THINK THEY MADE A
MISTAKE PUTTING YOU ON SUNDAY.
YOU'RE NOT CHRIS WALLACE.
>> Shannon: THAT'S TRUE.
>> Greg: AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING.
I'M KIDDING.
OR AM I.
JIMMY, ISN'T IT FUNNY THAT WHAT
JOE BIDEN IS DOING WITH THE
SAUDIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY
ACCUSED TRUMP WAS DOING WITH
UKRAINE.
>> Jimmy: SPOT ON, AND TO BE
CLEAR HE'S ONLY MAD AT THE
SAUDIS BECAUSE THEY GAVE HIM OIL
CANCER BACK IN THE CITIES.
THEY WERE THE ONES THAT SCREWED
UP THE WINDSHIELD WIPERS AND
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
IT READS LIKE A RIDICULOUS
SHAKEDOWN AND THE THING YOU READ
EARLIER ABOUT EVERYTHING BEING A
PROJECTION IS TRUE.
YOU CAN MAKE AN ARGUMENT THAT
WHEN YOU'RE CALLING THE BORDER
AGENTS RACIST, IT'S RACIST OF
YOU TO DO THAT NUMBER ONE, WHICH
IS VERY FRUSTRATING.
BUT THE BIGGER ISSUE THERE IS
MAYORKAS IS THE JUSSIE SMOLLETT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, THE ONLY THING HE LEFT
OUT IS THAT THE MIGRANTS WERE
GOING TO SUBWAY AND THE AGENTS
SAID IT WAS MAGA COUNTRY.
>> Greg: BY THE WAY JIMMY I
THINK THEY'RE APPLAUDING YOUR
BROKE BACK MOUNTAIN CASINO
CHURCH.
>> Jimmy: THEY'RE INTO THAT.
>> Greg: YEAH, THE DEVIL WENT
DOWN TO CHELSEA.
>> Jimmy: THE PEOPLE LIKE THE
GAME AND FISHING LOOK, I HAVE TO
BE HONEST.
I THINK THIS IS ALL SYSTEMATIC
IF YOU LOOK AT AWE THREE ROLLED
INTO ONE AS A PRESIDENT THAT
GETS ROLLED A LOT.
HE'S NOT REALLY IN CHARGE.
THEY WENT WITH THIS NARRATIVE
THAT HEY THE BORDER'S A
DISASTROUS FOR US POLITICALLY
LET'S MAKE THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT FAKE RACISM.
THE SAUDI SAME THING THE GREEN
ENERGY DEAL BIDEN SHOULD KNOW
BETTER THAN TO SUPPORT HE CAN'T
OVERCOME.
IN A NUTSHELL IF YOU LOOK AT
BIDEN HE SHOULD STEP ASIDE FOR
SOMEBODY YOUNGER LIKE MOSUS.
>> Greg: THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE MOSES
ISN'T ALIVE.
JIMMY BE REAL.
KAT WHAT PISSES YOU OFF THE MOST
IN THESE STORIES?
IS IT THE SAUDIS?
IS IT CHRISTOPHER STEEL?
THE FBI, THAT'S OUR MONEY
>> Kat: YEAH.
PLUS I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
ANYONE COULD HAVE EVER BELIEVED
THE PEE TAPE WAS REAL.
JUST BECAUSE I THINK THAT TRUMP
WAS PROBABLY BETTER AT REVENGE
THAN THAT.
IF SOMEBODY CAME UP TO ME AND
WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW THAT HOTEL
YOU STAYED AT THAT ONE TIME?
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE JUST PEED ON
THE BED.
I'D BE LIKE, OKAY.
>> Greg: YEAH, SO WHAT
>> Kat: I'M NOT STAYING THERE
TONIGHT.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> I WILL THOUGH
>> Kat: THE SAUDI THING FOR ALL
THE OBVIOUS REASONS UPSETS ME
BUT ALSO PART OF THE REASON WHY
WE'RE SO DESPERATE FOR OIL IS
BIDEN DOING ALL THESE THINGS TO
DECREASE OUR SUPPLY OF OIL AND
THEN BEING LIKE, OH, NO, WHERE'S
ALL THE OIL.
AND THE PRICES ARE HIGHER
BECAUSE THERE'S LESS OF IT.
THAT'S PRETTY BASIC STUFF AND
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS BUT WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP HAVING PROBLEMS
UNLESS THEY CAN ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THEMSELVES.
>> Greg: LIKE I SAID YESTERDAY
SNEAKY REPLAY OF HIDING THE
HUNTER BIDEN TAPE THE TIMING OF
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT HURT THEM
THEY BURY TYRUS.
LAST WORD TO YOU.
>> Tyrus: WE HAVE TO STOP GIVING
THIS ADMINISTRATION THE BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT.
WE HAVE TO STOP DOING THAT.
HE 1,000% KNEW WHAT HE WAS
DOING.
BUT LET'S REMEMBER DURING THIS
TIME WHAT WAS THE PLAN.
IT WAS TO BRING DOWN LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACROSS THE BOARD.
SO THIS MAN HAD THE AUDACITY TO
GO ON THERE KNOWING FULL WELL
THAT CALLING THESE AGENTS WHAT
HE CALLED THEM DIDN'T JUST
AFFECT THE AGENTS, THEIR
FAMILIES, THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS,
THEIR FRIENDS, HOW THEY'RE
LOOKED AT.
THEY PUT THEIR LIVES IN DANGER.
FOR WHAT?
BECAUSE IT WAS PART -- IT'S THE
PROGRESSIVE AGENDA, TEAR DOWN
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS WAS A CARROT.
THEY HAD A PICTURE THAT LOOKED
BAD AND HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE
SEEN THIS WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT?
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE SEEN THE
LAST EIGHT SECONDS OF A VIDEO
WHERE THEY'RE TAKING DOWN A
SUSPECT WHO'S BEEN RESISTING
ARREST FOR FIVE HOURS?
WE SEE THE LAST SECOND OF IT AND
WHAT, THEY'RE RACIST COPS THAT
WERE BASICALLY FIGHTING FOR
THEIR LIVES.
WELL, BAD THINGS -- I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT THEM.
I'M TALKING ABOUT GOOD COPS THAT
CAN'T GO TO WORK ANYMORE DON'T
WORK ANYMORE BECAUSE OF [BLEEP]
LIKE THIS.
THE FACT THAT HE DIDN'T STEP
DOWN IMMEDIATELY, THE FACT THAT
THE PRESIDENT, NOT ONLY -- I
MEAN WHY SHOULD HE STEP DOWN,
THE PRESIDENT LITERALLY BACKED
HIM UP AND SAID THERE WOULD BE
CONSEQUENCES.
WHERE'S THE CONSEQUENCES FOR YOU
GUYS?
AND THEY STILL HAVE THE BALLS
RIGHT NOW RIGHT NOW TO
ADMINISTRATIVELY PENDING?
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
STEP DOWN.
WE'VE GOT WHAT, 23 DAYS?
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Tyrus: I WOULD ASK IF
REPUBLICANS TAKE THE HOUSE OR
THE SENATE THE FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS GETTING THAT MAN OUT
OF HIS JOB
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
ROUSING, ROUSING APPLAUSE.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
YOU WANT HIM TO TAKE MY JOB?
NEVER APPLAUD MORE FOR HIM THAN
YOU DO FOR ME.
>> Tyrus: DIDN'T YOU SIGN A